le tour de france passera par les
yvelines au minimum jusqu'en 2023 les
organisateurs et le département signé
une convention en ce sens ce mercredi 20
mars
objectif préparer les jeux olympiques
2024 avec notamment un départ en 2023 du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à toutes les
épreuves cyclistes qu'elle soit à
l'intérieur du vélodrome ou à
l'extérieur le bmx le vtt le vélo sur
route tout se tient dans les yvelines
il était donc pour nous logique de
préparer ce très grand moment
on reverra pas les olympiques en france
avant des décennies et donc le
département veut monter en puissance
pour les organisateurs ce partenariat
avec les yvelines marque une continuité
dans l'histoire du tour de france le
tour de france dès sa première édition
en 1903 et pas fait sur le territoire
des yvelines c'était la seine et oise à
l'époque juste avant l'arrivée de la
dernière étape et c'est d'ailleurs le
vainqueur du tour de france du premier
tour de france maurice guérin qui avait
gagné cette étape là donc il ya un tas
d'histoires qui sont passés dans le
département en une échappée formidable
de bernard hinault avec son rival
laurent gbagbo tomek voilà jusqu'aux
dernières éditions pour cette première
collaboration dans ce partenariat
rambouillet a été retenue comme ville
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
le dimanche 28 juillet une première
depuis 2012 donc on attend bien sûr
beaucoup de monde
40000 spectateurs en 2012 on va essayer
de battre le record
on attend du tourisme on attend une
image rambouillet est déjà connu au
niveau international la dernière étape
est une des étapes les plus regardées du
tour de france donc voilà c'est l'image
l'identité de rambouillet et c'est une
magnifique identité qu'on veut que le
monde entier connaît ça après
rambouillet le peloton devrait passer
par la vallée de chevreuse jouy en josas
but qu'avant de quitter le département à
vélizy villacoublay